hello everybody I'm sorry aunty I'm Dan
Hynes
and today we are looking at a very
special game which is an alpha at the
moment it's called wolf the red Diaries
or the Red Hood Diaries little indie
game looks really interesting and it's a
platformer a puzzle platformer as well
involving a girl who's very much
resembles good Riding Hood fairies would
you say that it is a dark and gritty
take on the Red Riding Hood children's
tale I would say so but not it has less
to do with the tale and it's more lifted
big I guess the characters and the
themes so um it's like okay so you've
gone into the screen this is sort of 2.5
d yes it's like you can move left to
right but you can also come forward oh
that's interesting
which is interesting and jump is a
separate key on it's an and she's also
got this max yeah okay and there's two
attacks to this first one she does in
the second one which kind of looks very
similar to me I'm not really I'm sure
with it so it serves more of a purpose
okay but let's let's move on where are
you you're in some sewers right now this
is the alpha build that I'm playing at
the notice owed I think there are a lot
of animations and stuff that I notice
we're missing when I played it at the
time
but I guess it's kind of like the goal
is just solve puzzles and make it out
through these areas how do you know when
you need to go into the background you
don't really you just kind of run around
and look at where you need to go next so
here I can go like forward towards us
all I think or you can die in a steam
vent like a new so she does die in one
hit so obviously because I can't go that
way and the other way this there's
nothing really like it's a dead end
I'm just going to progress and see what
other avenues I've got left to explore
which would take me you can you smash
that box no I'm trying but you there's a
crater the video game when you can't
smash it this kind of reminds me a lot
of Alice madness Returns yes style and
the fact that they've booth lifts
you know there's subject matter fanfare
this wouldn't go astray being called
American McGee's Red Riding Hood no I
don't think together you have some
nonlinear level design here that
requires you to backtrack and explore
and and that sort of thing yeah and I
found in my time with the game so
father's quite a bit off like looping
around levels backtracking and figuring
out you know the puzzles aren't just
linear like yeah straight forward you're
progressing although that being said
there was another level in which you
know there was the puzzles where like
that you just could rest from like left
to right and you continue on with this
one is so much said Oh moving platforms
now yeah this will take a bit of tricky
plateau what are you doing I'm waiting
for the boxes to come oh you have to go
that way all right
yes but they end after a certain point
in which you have to wait for the loops
to stop a typical box in a platforming
game I gotta say it's very strange being
able to come like forward as well yeah
left and right and when you're jumping
you can like you can miscalculate bangle
it looks like it would take a lot of
practice to get the depth perception
right because the game is at a very
oblique angle and so it's not as sort of
top-down but you kind of want when
you're timing chomps yeah and like there
was at one point where I was jumping in
like and I didn't realize I am gold it
wrongly and I went into a wall slightly
and that pushed me into the into the
water and I died yeah that was
interesting this just reminded me a lot
of the Abe's Oddysee remake you know
they were a lot of like grinding things
that are gonna chop you up in one hand
and kill you yeah yeah yeah yeah and
actually another game that it reminded
me of us trying
except of course we're playing it's just
one character China has definitely that
fantasy vibe that this is sort of
not emulating but kinda has a lot in
common with yes that's that's wolf the
Red Hood Diaries and as you can see you
can kick start that game if you like to
find out more about it check out all the
content we've got on gaze for calm